what are you doing going back to my room
I didn't do nothing
[Music]
home what happened to your face this
little going away present from the boys
out early you ain't on my reach boy
you're being awful hard on yourself we
can be forgiven
around here ain't no point of keeping it
to secret one of our own shot with his
own pistol which we can't seem to find
[Music]
turn on the car and drive
oh I think I'll hold on to that this
ain't too good
I shot him until he wasn't moving no
more I know a place you can go somewhere
safe I'm gonna trust you you're gonna
have to trust me
what the hell is going on I need that
old place I'll explain everything later
all right I got your back
a woman came into the shelter little
girl that lady working there said she
found a pistol on her before she took
off running
I just need to know if Russell stayed
here with you tonight before last as far
as I know he was here
I'm brother dead I ain't looking to be
another
[Music]
guy together by some sort of the
invisible Road
just do the best you can for right now
you don't worry about tomorrow until it
comes
David somebody help us
[Music]
this is the end for us Life's a
whirlwind
we're all caught up in it